you know we always talk about how
communication is important in
relationships right yeah so I've had
quite a few experiences we talked about
it earlier with the guys
we're mean someone else will establish
set rules for our dynamic we move
forward with that understanding so let's
say the girl comes to me she says I just
I came out of relationship I want to
keep it casual
yeah I'm like okay all right so I'm
shutting that thing off of my head right
and then I've had girls come back
afterwards and when I no longer want
engaged in that casual experience all
right oh so you're just gonna manipulate
my emotions and then walk away
afterwards and I'm just like what what
are you talking about what's happening
right now I've even had an experience
with a girl what I wanted to be in
relationship with her broach the subject
she refused I said cool but she wants us
to keep seeing each other casually I
said all right you know I mean I'm not
gonna complain you know mm-hmm ten weeks
later I'm like all right well I just
think we should stop seeing each other
and she said well I want to be in a
relationship with you and I'm like well
I'm not there anymore you rejected me
I've kind of moved on emotionally now
you want me to still be open she's like
well yes you're exactly like that you
just get see me that way and I'm like
what you know where do you even get off
being that arrogant where you are
perfectly fine to trample on my feelings
and I have no problem with it I respect
it because you're right to say no but if
I exercise my right to say no you're
gonna try to emotionally manipulate me
into feeling guilty about it as if I
somehow messed up hmm I'm not surprised
by it but I'm just like why don't you
just accept responsibility as a mix of a
couple of things right the first thing
would be and we all recovered this
subject it is the fact that most women
to have a problem dealing with rejection
okay because they're not they're not
used to deal with rejection as much as
man in general you think what you said
was oh they manipulate my feelings no
because it's really not intentional it's
really in their perception of things
when you change your mind is because you
manipulate them they think we are always
playing a game if nothing changed on my
side I'm so good I didn't change
anything how can you
not fill this anymore it's a transfer of
power you know cuz because she has the
power she has the power to say she has
the power to say yes or no she has the
power to be like hey listen
oh well that's why I don't it's like
when you ask for a dance man they're
gonna go get the girls but girls are
gonna be the dog that actually be saying
yes or no we're gonna propose but the
lady at the end of the day is gonna be
the one saying yes or no okay
no no no I know it's a chance for a
power and they're not using that sense
for a power that's the gender role that
we had established for years and years
and years that's how it works man
propose and they say yes or no now you
took that you said yes sir no no now you
just want to manipulate the game you
want to manipulate the game and you want
to have power if that was that's why
they don't get it you think they're
being arrogant right and they think
you're playing games when it's really
not bad you just didn't feel like it
anymore and said no I'm gonna move on to
the you know Americans comes from my the
arrogance that I'm I'm I think I'm
feeling because because if this if the
roles were reversed if I rejected a curl
but we kept seeing each other and then I
developed feelings and she's like I'm no
longer there I would never think of
being like oh so your feelings were
faked no if you if the roles were
reversed you'd be a girl and she'd be a
man and the same thing would happen but
to her okay if the roles were reversed
that's what would have happened it
wouldn't be if cuz that's the role that
we have any nice men and women yes okay
that's the role that we had so if her
saying no to you as a woman saying no to
you it's not the same thing as you say
no to her it's not because you don't
have the same roles okay same the same
thing ask if your mom says if your mom
when you're growing up she says no
that's a note but if your five-year-old
you look at your mama you're like no you
don't get it woman you're gonna get it
because you don't have the same role
okay now I'm not saying that women or
kids and men are
it's not even that it's just really
there they're equal but different roles
different roles and that's what it is so
you say no to a woman in a relationship
does not equate her saying no to you
because of the fact that she's a woman
because you're a man and because they're
in the roles that are very much
established and this is what happening
so it's really just a thing of
perception and that's what happening
right now I also think it's a matter of
just responsibility you don't take any
accountability for the fact that you're
feeling hurt right now this is somehow
all my fault this is something I did to
you yes and you don't see how you
contribute you took the power no but
that power that you're talking about
right like that part it's not just it's
not power than I'm exercising I know
it's more so I've changed where I am
yeah so I've let go of something right
but hopefully it's like you contributed
to me letting go when I wanted you to
hand it to you you said you wanted no
part of it
so I discarded it and now that you're
handing something out to me you just
expect me to come and grab it so like
you can't stand but if she said no to
you she still has the power to say yes
or no in her mind so if you turn now
you're like oh okay and you turn away
and now she wants it she like no I'm
good I'm not there no more but to her in
their inner perception she said no to
you man
you stayed there and now she feeling you
that's manipulation you charmed her that
that's what it is and now not that she
wants it and you're like nah ah you
played that game you stayed and you
manipulated me in liking you now he's
just gonna say no how could you do it
like that if you said it
it always impresses me yo there always
impresses rub where when things don't
work out in the dating experience
there's no cheating no nothing just like
yeah I'm not interested anymore it's
always some matter of the man having
some kind of ulterior motive of being a
bad person
not being evil the reality is I just may
not be interested in you it may not be
up my alley
sometimes you know and I'm surprised
that women don't get it you guys are the
same people who go to the store buy
something and return it the next day you
guys are used to changing your minds all
the time go - a good that's the reality
so why is it that if I change my mind
somehow now it's because I'm going
through something no I'm not some
terrible day I'm just not there anymore
question the perception it's just like
that it's really did your gonna analyze
and over and I analyzed everything and
when you're just gonna which is you know
it's one thing that's why they're very
good and they're gonna overanalyze
everything okay
so you stayed I said no to you you
stayed that long so you stayed that long
to make me feel so you staying that long
just to me just to take a with that
power means you're a bad person be here
if you want that's what over analyzing
that sometimes you be like well don't be
like what do you mean you don't want a
statement I'm not interested like well
then why would you do this and that
you mean like why would I be nice to you
why would I know there's no no you're
manipulating my kindness used against me
you know as some kind of evidence that I
was trying to do something no what I did
in terms of bringing you food isn't an
indication that I somehow want to be
with you for the rest of my life I want
to be open to that possibility it's me
doing something kind for someone I like
that's it okay I wouldn't be with you I
wouldn't date somebody if I didn't like
them but because they they they we all
do that they do it too but they don't
notice that they do it how is a woman
how is the woman gonna say sorry you
sorry I messed up in this society in
this toxic community because it does
exist and we're gonna do but that's
another subject but they're not gonna
say sorry we're the ones that have to
say sorry ah
I disagree I've had with plenty of women
apologize to me fine purchase yo Hatchin
check you I demand an apology when you
cross my bone logo so you demand an
apology maybe that's why you've been i
don't demand it I said like I demand one
I basically I make it clear that if you
don't make amends I'm not moving
that violated my tribe you ever had your
parents beat you or say something to you
and you're like your mom's like she
knows she messed up until she beat your
ass and your mom is like bye-bye tough
family it's a long-term relationship
wave apologize early on women better use
their words because they don't have time
to kind of do that kind of thing
preserving your ego and those kind of
dating situation so what are you gonna
do security are they gonna be what are
you gonna do you gonna be lying in bed
and what they're gonna do push up their
bomb of you know that's definite
technique I've heard of to be clear to
be clear with me
I won't let you move past this you I'm
not talking about talking about you I'm
talking about their psyche and the
winner relationship work right you're
right right I'm not talking about you
know you're right if you make a man's
and stuff like that fine but she's gonna
still gonna try to do something and try
to be like yeah so she they're not you
they're not used to that and I saying
sorry stuff like that so that's pretty
much wasn't happiness
I also needs to stop commenting or
replying to me or sending a message
where do you find these women listen I'm
not picking women out of some cuckoo
nest these are regular people and you
know what tells me about a lot people
where do you find these women those very
women that had to be guilty of the same
behavior you don't when you find out
where you fight they're the one that
they're the perpetrator everyone thinks
that they're never able to do that and
then they end up in a relationship and
they exhibit the same behavior like is
everybody so don't even
are you find these people it reminds me
of like su it reminds me of feminists
who be like oh me too me too
and then you just wake up and your P
noir is in their mouth yeah Oh YouTube
you do right so just all right well
listen that's it for today's topic we
just want to kind of probe sis just like
the open-ended discussion but we want to
know your experiences guys have you guys
ever had this happen to ladies will you
ever done this or had it happened to you
we want to see so we can learn all
righty so I broke it down but if I'm
wrong let me know yeah we want to just
have this conversation I think these are
stuff in dating that are worth talking
yeah so leave your comments below and
let's talk about it bones
we have won some battles
[Music]